the search for seasonal cheer amid the
winter worries is on but as the
Christmas Market season begins the
chancellor has the small matter of an
Autumn statement and he told Sky News
they will be absolutely no presence we
do have to
um do some tax Rises do some spending
cuts if we're going to show that we're a
country that pays our way and and we're
now in a situation where the world has
changed very dramatically over the last
year
but the plan that we'll outline will
help us get through this in a way that I
want to make sure that this recession if
we're in a recession is as short and
shallow as possible Jeremy Hunt was
blunt to restore the countries and the
conservatives economic credibility
everyone will pay we need to recognize
that there's only so much you can ask
from people on the very lowest income so
that will be reflected in the decisions
that I take and I think that's important
because Britain is a decent country a
fair country a compassionate country so
you'll be paying a bit more tax then
after next week but we're all going to
be paying a bit more tax I'm afraid
Sophie the chancellor is understood to
be targeting tax Rises and spending cuts
worth between 50 and 60 billion pounds
tax thresholds the level above Which tax
is paid will be frozen meaning more
people will pay more tax as wages rise
and energy support could be reduced by
as much as 600 pounds per household in a
real economy facing recession and 10
inflation consumers and businesses are
already feeling the chill probably the
average spend is probably down so that
certainly reflects on people are being
more careful we've turned down the
heating and I'm getting used to it not
being quite so
[Music]
know about how yeah what we've got to
come people have been a lot more
they want it right as the boasters and
so I love that I'll have it if Jeremy
Hunt sounds a bit like Scrooge it's
deliberate he wants to convince the
financial markets that Britain can be
trusted to balance a budget of his
choosing after the chaos of Liz trusses
policies he might also want to get all
the bad news out now in the hope that by
next Christmas or certainly the next
election things might have improved
labor Hope by then the job of economic
recovery Falls to them and urges the
chancellor to Target big business there
are fair choices that the chancellor
could be making this week rather than
just putting all of that burden on
ordinary working people who are already
struggling with the highest inflation
that any of us have experienced for 40
years and now risk more of their money
going in taxes rather than having it for
the weekly food shop the higher mortgage
payments
summoning the festive Spirit may be
tricky this year with the economic
Outlook Bleak bad tidings cold comfort
and precious little Joy Paul Kelso Sky
News